they used to be called Factory schools
for a long time they were literally
called Factory schools why they were
training kids to sit at a desk follow
orders do their little task be a cog in
a machine raise their hand if they need
to go to the bathroom and it was widely
perceived in a very positive way that
this was going to help prepare kids for
having good jobs we see this today even
though we have a totally different
economy though we have the same
education system from a century ago that
was for a different economy but we see
it today with things like Common Core
and No Child Left Behind and other
emphases that are focusing on what are
called College and Career Readiness so
the purported purpose today of the K-12
system is to basically prepare children
for higher education and for uh for the
economy what's fascinating I
unfortunately don't recall off the top
of my head who did the poll we cite it
in the book but just a few months ago
this huge poll came out and they did a
really interesting uh had an interesting
methodology they were asking parents
their own perspective of how they
prioritize K-12 education in other words
why do you think K-12 education is
important for your child but then they
also ask them how they perceive others
uh rank that type of perception so
College and Career Readiness right
parents for their own children
prioritize that very low on the spectrum
of priorities they they de-emphasize
that they didn't think it was that
important however when they were asked
what they perceived society and their
peers prioritize it it was very high
because everyone thinks that that's why
we educate kids that's why we put them
through all the misery of you know all
these years of schooling is so that
they'll have a good job is so that
they'll be prepared for the future what
ranked at the top for parents uh two
things practical skill development not
these abstract ideas of you know getting
you ready for a future career but very
practical skills financial management
and everything else and number two is
critical thinking and and if you were to
assess the modern education system based
on those things I think it ranks very
poorly the push for Charter Schools as
you point out in the 90s I think is best
contextualized as coming on the
coattails of the reforms in the 80s with
homeschooling homeschooling was was
effectively illegal in Most states until
a lot of Court battles throughout the
80s that really sparked a wave of kind
of parental rights and educational
reform and interest in saying hey we
need Alternatives there had been a large
underground homeschooling movement of
course but this was kind of brought
above board in part with the support of
groups like The Home School legal
defense Association that went and fought
and knocked down a lot of these state
laws leading leading us to the 90s as
you point out with the charter school
movement this idea that rather than a
one-size-fits-all approach rather than
you know we do it this way in this
school and here's the conveyor belt what
if we could create some flexibility
within the system they weren't
questioning the system overall they
weren't saying let's have education you
know savings accounts or vouchers or
whatever but hey could we have schools
that look a little bit differently that
operate a little bit differently I'm
ultimately not a big fan of charter
schools just because I I don't think
that they've lived up to the vision of
their original proponents a lot of times
they devolve into kind of lipstick on a
pig in the sense that they have
superficial differences and some
marginal differences but fundamentally
they're all following the same
curriculum standards and required to do
things largely the same way that happens
in the public schools but you can do you
can certainly see in the early stages of
those battles again on the coattails of
the homeschooling reforms and increased
desire which now is is substantially
larger for parents to say we need
something different because the status
quo isn't working what for you what is
the vision of you know what what is what
is uh you know education for in two
minutes or less here we go okay so
um you know the root word of Education
when you look at the etymology it is to
draw out the modern school system is
trying to fill and cram kids full of
knowledge just in case they ever need it
30 years from now and need to remember
that the mitochondrion is the PowerHouse
of the cell I think by contrast true
education is trying to draw out it is a
Socratic method it is trying to
challenge kids and adults to think
critically about their own ideas to
identify where they can find that
information from so I think what we
ultimately need is educational
entrepreneurship it's why I'm so bullish
on micro schools because what you're
finding is a lot of teachers who are fed
up with the bureaucracy they make way
more money and have total freedom
starting their own school and then they
can Cobble together curriculum and
activities and projects from a variety
of sources my own kids go to an actin
Academy I'm a huge fan of acting
academies they're all over the country
can you explain what that is yeah yeah
they're kind of a montessori-like
private school typically they're micro
schools these are small schools but
they're very Socratic in nature it's
project-based learning it's self-guided
that there are no teachers the kids are
in charge of their own education the
adults are what are called guides so
they're there to help when needed but
they provide all these resources to kids
they provide them the time and the
educational freedom to follow their
Curiosities and figure out what they
want to do they have a peer Community
there to kind of debate and challenge
ideas and work together on projects and
it provides the children not only a lot
more self-ownership to direct their own
education but the freedom to do so the
biggest thing that we stifled for kids
that was stifled for me as a graduate of
what I call the public school system was
that I had no education freedom I would
be curious about things I would raise my
hand hey why you know are we learning
this oh put your hand down it'll be on
the test so fundamentally Corey
mentioned this earlier it's a
pseudo-monopoly fundamentally what I
believe the school system needs is
competition we know that that's how
things improve and prices go down I'm
not so uh I'm not a central planner I'm
not going to say we should re-architect
all of K-12 education based on this I
think though systematically what we need
is to introduce competition to the
system and unleash education
entrepreneurship to find a diversity of
approaches and curricula and options
that can best resonate with each unique
individual experience we don't really
have that we have a small amount but
with all these states passing education
savings accounts and other reforms I
think I'm increasingly hopeful about the
future that we're going to have more of
a Marketplace of educational approaches
to to help kids in the future that was
an excerpt from reasons live stream with
Corey DeAngelis and Conor boyak the
authors of mediocrity 40 ways government
schools are failing today's students if
you want to see the full conversation go
here if you want to see another excerpt
go here and make sure to come back next
Thursday every Thursday at 1 pm eastern
time when Zach weismiller and I are
doing a live stream with somebody very
interesting that you are definitely
going to want to know about